[Musique] la
chambre est au dernier étage c'est parfait
j'adore ça
je pourrais vivre n'importe où à n'importe quel moment je
vivrais ici à Londres
dans les années 60
[Musique]
hier soir
j'ai vu quelque chose dans mes rêves
[Musique]
il y avait une fille
et tu es sablonneux
[Musique]
j'ai ce genre de cadeau
je peux voir que les visages des gens
sont de ce genre c'est
ce que la plupart des gens se rapprochent le plus
de leurs rêves
ce ne sont pas juste des rêves
jack je ne veux pas faire ça  tu penses que
tu peux juste t'en aller
c'est vraiment arrivé
qu'as-tu vu
crois-tu aux fantômes
tu as été témoin du meurtre hier soir mais
tu crois que c'était une vision du
passé
[Musique]
le gars qui l'a tuée est toujours comme
ça
je dois  arrête-le
où tu
vas je sais ce que tu as fait j'ai fait
beaucoup de choses
tu peux devoir être plus précis
mon amour tu ne peux pas me sauver
toi